never
chase the hot thing whatever it is
that's that's like trying to catch the
wave and you'll never catch it you need
to position yourself and wait for the
wave and the way you do that is you pick
something you're passionate about so
that that's the number one piece of
advice
that i give to somebody who wants to
start a company or or start a new
endeavor inside of a bigger company
make sure it's something you're
interested in something you're
passionate about missionaries build
better products
and so
i would take a missionary over a
mercenary any day mercenaries want to
you know
flip the company and get rich
missionaries
want to build a great product or service
and you know one of those great
paradoxes it's usually the missionaries
who end up making more money anyway
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from super successful
entrepreneurs
enjoy
lesson number two position yourself with
jack ma richard nixon came to hangzhou
yeah and after that tours flooded the
place yeah and that's how you learned
english yeah
i really
like the i don't know why at 12 13 years
old that time i suddenly felt love into
the language the english
and there's no place you can you can
learn english at that time there's no
books english books
so i went to the uh hanzo hotel now
called hanzo shangri-la hotel because
that was the hotel
i can receive the foreign visitors so
every morning for nine years i showed
them a run as a free guide and they told
me english
and i think that changed me today i'm
100 made in china i've never got a one
day train outside china
and uh people when people talk to me say
jack how can you speak english like that
why sometimes you you talk like amer
western guys
i think that was the nine years
these
western for
tourists opened my mind
because everything they told me are so
different from the things i learned from
the schools and from my parents
so
now i have a habit whatever i see
whatever i read i use my mind think
about for two minutes lesson number
three get still with oprah winfrey as
you're trying to figure out what do i do
how should i do it first of all i will
say this
that when you don't know what to do my
girls have heard this over a hundred
times when you don't know what to do you
do nothing
you get still until you do know
because when you have to ask everybody
else should i should i should i do this
[ __ ] i should have and that's whether
it's buying a pair of shoes or going
with a guy buying a house taking a job
should i should i should i when you have
to ask everybody else it means you don't
really know the answer fully yourself so
you get still be still
and know
the answer will come
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four make things go
fast with elon musk underneath your
beautiful beast yeah it's crazy can you
believe this even is even here
i was here a month ago literally
standing right here well not just over
the fence right and you know you had a
tube and a pointy tube
and now you've got this i mean how do
you how do you do that is it just sheer
will
is it everyone that driven about the
goal
i think i've learned a lot of lessons
about how to make things go fast um and
then i've
been uh
um
propagated those lessons to the spacex
team and
there's just like an incredibly talented
hard-working team at spacex
in fact at times i think maybe there's
too many talented people at spacex where
like
you know too many talented people that
were cornering the markets
um you know but there's like a very
talented group that works super hard and
uh
the
and and just have
taking the general approach of if if a
design is taking too long the design is
wrong and therefore the design must be
modified right um to accelerate progress
lesson number five learn the art of
entrepreneurship with richard branson i
was interested um
as a sort of young young
14 15 year old about and what was going
on around the world and
um and i was inquisitive
and
uh and the vietnamese war uh was raging
and um
it seemed to me as it seemed to a lot of
young people a very unjust war
uh as most wars actually turn out to be
and um
and
i like a lot of other people wanted a
campaign to try to stop it
and
there was no
uh
young person's magazine at the time
and um and it's quite strange because
i'm dyslexic and that i should
feel that i can
uh
who's dyslexic in this room
all the best people in the world are
just like sorry with the rest of you but
anyway
um they um
uh but um yeah so being dyslexic
thinking that i could be an editor of a
magazine but um but anyway i thought i
could give it a shot and but and
and so i decided to leave school and
start a magazine to
uh yeah a campaigning magazine to try to
reform education and try to tackle
issues like like things like the
vietnamese war and the biafran war and
other wars that were going on at the
time um i never thought i i was becoming
an entrepreneur i don't think the word
entrepreneur actually existed 50 years
ago and in britain all businesses were
run by
governments really british gas versus
coal british telecom british airways you
know and
uh so the word
entrepreneur didn't really exist
um
but in
starting this magazine i had to make
sure it survived i didn't have any money
so
um so i had to worry about printing and
paper manufacturing and distribution and
selling it and
and that started
taking up quite a lot of time and
uh and the word survival was very
important because in those days
you couldn't uh raise money to start
your businesses you had to sort of try
to start them fund them just fund them
from people wanting to buy advertising
or buying copies of your magazine and um
so i learned i learned the art of being
an entrepreneur
uh by you know in the jungle trying
trying to survive and the magazine
became my education and
uh and it was a you know a lot of fun
and
and one thing one thing led on to
another lesson number six accept your
fear with mark cuban how do you fight
the fear to take the risk
you don't you accept it and you use that
as motivation i can't even tell you how
many times i was terrified you know when
i first started my business barbara's
right you know when you're broke you got
nowhere to go but uh i was sleeping on
the floor eat mustard and ketchup
sandwiches i had nothing to lose
and so you know and i was terrified that
look if i didn't make my next sale my
business was over
and that just kept me going because i
didn't like sleeping on the floor i
didn't like gaining 30 pounds because
the only place i really ate anything was
going to a bar buy one two dollar beer
and eating 30 worth of fried mushrooms
and that motivated me just to keep going
and going and you know that that fear is
going to be inside of you no matter what
i don't care where you are in your life
you are going to be afraid at some level
and you just gotta keep on working and
part two to that is if you do the work
and you're prepared that's what builds
confidence to overcome that fear and
work through it and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is invest money with grant
cardone when i read these books in my
20s about successful people
they all they all owned real estate
all the successful people the the
rockefellers the oil barons the railroad
guys they all ended up with real estate
car dealers car dealers don't make money
selling cars just so you know
car dealers make money
because they pay for their real estate
they rent it back to the store and they
end up with a facility that pays them
forever for for acres and acres of real
estate just so you know every car dealer
in america gets rich because of their
real estate not just because of their
cars the cars pay for the real estate
how many of you know a rich car dealer
okay mcdonald's ray kroc
he didn't he didn't have the recipe he
got control of mcdonald's because
of real estate
jeff bezos today in every major city in
america right now is making real estate
place
so
you're here because you already
understand that i understood it and i
started writing this down 20 units or
more
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things nice i like them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning
uh sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got went back to the bookstore bought
every book of the color purple i took
the books to to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i pass out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's gonna do a movie about
the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jarrett curl
on am
chicago quincy jones tells ruben cannon
the casting agent i think i found sophia
so i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
no
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl or the best
girl they are asking me do i want a part
in the movie oh that i'm thinking prayer
prayer works
prayer works
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying i can't believe that god has
played this trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god
i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
you all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the truck so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord don't come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress in my part i won't be able
to see it won't be able to see color
purple just can't never see it the rest
of my life i won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
[Music]
surrender all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i
surrender all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming offering
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired at what point was it
where you guys said huh you know what we
might be on to something here with these
paul mitchells you know shampoo and
conditioners which you guys came to be
known for what was the point where you
guys said hmm like let's do this like
what was the well we were planning to do
it because i knew the business i was in
marketing sales and structure and had
connections with uh product development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was the perfect
combination these two guys together
we're just the best of friends and we
knew we could do it uh obviously we
started out with nothing we made the
decision let's just let's just make this
happen and as you will see and your
guests will see when they look at good
fortune the movie and it's on itunes
it's on amazon all those whenever you
look at it it's the whole story of
starting in america with nothing a
couple times and making things happen
because of what you believe in but the
important thing is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we don't want
to shake your hand to that sure you
betcha but i applaud you for that that's
awesome it's still going on that one i
have had before co-partners
in some businesses i've tried and not as
good as my partner paul mitchell but in
other businesses and they didn't turn
out to be what i thought they would be
so if you have a partner one you've got
to be friendly to one another you also
have to have your boundaries where okay
i live my life you live your life we
can't live it all together we're
together we have a certain goal now if
you do have i call it a challenge
opposed to a problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
don't attack on it instead it's much
easier to say
well you know this uh you're you're a
wonderful person we've done some really
great business together but with all due
respect when i came in here i had a
great idea wanted to tell you and you
kept on cutting me off and it made me
feel bad liz you know as well that just
made me feel bad and i know you'd like
to hear it i just wanted to share that
with you you share your feelings with
the person if they have an id you don't
think it's any good you could say you
know that's
that that's a great idea i could
appreciate where you're coming from
always validate the person however can
we look at this a little differently
maybe we can enhance it and build upon
it and you come in with your two cents
always respect the other person the
biggest impact a company can have is
staying within its area of expertise
so
you know to make sure that
the education systems around the world
that they get good software and we have
a donation program where we've done
called it's called partners and learning
we have deals with 132 countries
how we grant them software and fund
teacher training in each of those
countries so
microsoft's main thing will be about
that library access that school access
the free software the training you know
the job skills and the partners that are
in that
country
uh not
not
not so much health care and
whereas the big drug companies we need
to get them into the health care issues
and the banks we need to get into
microfinance and the food companies we
need to get into micronutrients and
buying the output of the farmers in
these poor countries so that the their
economies get going so i think
everybody's got a big role to play
but it's it's going to be fairly
centered on the thing that that the
employees know and
drives their their specific contribution
i remember one great fear i had uh
when we did microsoft research was that
they
if we weren't careful it'd be
a block to our view of what was going on
in the academic community that is we
would hire somebody
who had an approach
and that academia as a whole would have
like 20 approaches you know
number of which would likely be better
than some internal approach and so i
wanted somebody who was open-minded
enough to say no the you know this group
here
uh is doing it the right way
uh and i was worried would that fluidity
exist so a lot of these programs like
having students come here like the
faculty summit have contributed to the
idea that okay we're part of a broader
committee community
we publish great things you know people
come and go
a lot so i feel super good about that
in terms of work uh
you know i would say the most of the
opportunity to make computers improve
work is in front of us instead of behind
us
only at kind of a very mechanical level
of
it's better than white out
uh
you know are we like oh wow this thing
helps me get my work done uh for
extremely structured tasks like creating
financial statements you know where the
application logic is very opaque and
you're just led through it or for very
horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the machine doesn't see
oh that email is part of personnel
review that email's part of planning the
uh the salesforce meeting so we have
kind of the the low-level horizontal
which in this way is
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world
the idea of of
matching
what you and your head have as the
intention of the overall activity in the
semantics around it
uh and therefore sort of maximally
helping you with those things i think
now
uh that a lot of base level things are
are done very well including gathering
the data and learning from it that we
should be able to
have what the machine thinks you're up
to and what you think you're up to match
each other
uh and improve the productivity quality
quality quite dramatically you can't get
what you want by focusing on what you
don't want
this is about the need to
establish as many meaningful connections
as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way to connect to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division
and embrace the places that bond us
where we find
our human ground you famously started
spanx with five thousand dollars in your
bank account what was the hardest part
about getting spanx off the ground
um the hardest part about getting spanx
off the ground was definitely in the
very beginning when you have when you
first have an idea as an inventor and
you thought of something that doesn't
exist and you want to bring it into the
world
there were two things that were
happening one was my own self-doubt was
a really hard part of the journey and um
and then the beginning of all the
manufacturers that i was having to cold
call and talk to to try to get my
product made were all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so i heard the word no
for two straight years trying to get it
made which then increases the self-doubt
that can happen
and
one of the interesting things about
being an inventor is you don't go to
school for it there isn't an inventor
class you can't major in inventing and
so it's really a belief system in
yourself and the willingness to look
stupid or to have people laugh at you or
to fail
at something that you believe in you're
your own gut check on that and so it
takes a lot of confidence so that was
that was the hardest part of my journey
there was a lot of starting and stopping
and like am i crazy and everyone's
saying no and
but i you know i kept
picking myself back up to pursue it well
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother and me to fail
so at the dinner table he would actually
ask us what did you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me
and
what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize that at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about not trying
and
so you know the fear of failure as we
all know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something um
and so i you know i incorporate that in
my philosophy at spanx we have we
celebrate failures we talk about them we
have oops meetings where i'll announce
the oops that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach
theme songs to our oops
and we'll play him in front of the whole
company but i think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not safe if i make mistakes
now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because
ai
is going to have more of an impact than
the internet did ai plus new types of
chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate them
right is as important because every
email y'all are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fine no one i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome i mean my dad busted his ass i
mean he worked six six days a week um
lit left at seven at seven seven thirty
in the morning got back at six or seven
o'clock
lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting um
some
covering on a car seat
um
you know it was it was a middle-class
upbrinking my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better i mean my grandparents came over
from russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were the
first generation americans like my mom
too and you know like every child of
immigrants they wanted better for their
kids you know it's funny i mean a lot of
people grow up that way right but not
many people end up like you so what do
you think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it
and i found out early that i was a good
salesperson that i really liked business
you know like i like sports i mean i
read everything i possibly could played
sports as much as i could just wasn't as
good as i wanted to be and and business
was the same way i mean as long as i
could remember i was buying and selling
baseball cards garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps
um to collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i have my ups and downs along the way of
course but um i just think that i just i
just put in the time and was fortunate
enough to really get excited about
business and that paid off benefits over
the long haul you know i kind of think
about what we're doing today
um very similarly to how i thought about
where we were at the beginning you know
it's uh you know i get people all the
time who come to me and say all right
well you're investing billions of
dollars in trying to
put internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
um it's not something that uh will that
we'll make any money from for a very
long period of time if it works out but
you know it's this deep belief that
you're trying to make a change you're
trying to connect people in the world
and i really do believe that if you do
something good and if you help people
out then eventually some portion of that
good will come back to you and you may
not know up front what it's going to be
but
that's just been the guiding principle
for me in the work that we've done so
throughout building facebook i mean
there have been lots of challenges and
there are all these times where in
anything you do where you know you're
really going to be pushed and you
feel like you want to give up or
something like that and
you know this gets back to
i was talking a second ago about how
i think the media there's a little bit
of this cultural bias towards thinking
that you know one person does this right
i mean people say that you know i built
facebook or steve jobs built apple or
whatever but you know that's really not
true right i mean it's we're we're
people we we helped uh but
there were thousands and thousands of
other people involved in building these
things and the reality is is that as
strong as any one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them in anything that you do
and
one of the ways that i think we maintain
resilience is by having co-founders and
partners who
complement our strengths and
fortify our weaknesses and can kind of
encourage us and give us a push to to
keep going when things are tough and
there's actually a lot of data on this
that suggests that companies that get
started with more co-founders are more
likely to be successful
and it isn't quite clear
exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear in terms
of the outcome for the startups that it
is the case um but i would guess
that the reason why that's the case is
because of this resilience point where
people who start something by themselves
i just think like there's no way that
any one person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
to build a startup or take on any kind
of other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
i don't know i mean maybe over time one
of them
doesn't like it and drops out but you
still have enough strength on the team
to power through all the challenges that
you have and that's kind of how you go
today oracle employs around 150 000
people
but when i started
it was not my intention
to build a big company
what happened
well at first we did exactly what we set
out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team
plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company
i call it a crazy idea
because at the time
everyone told me it was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published and ibm was building a
prototype in their research labs
but back then
the collective wisdom of computer
experts
was that while relational databases
could be built
they would never be fast enough to be
useful
i thought
all those so-called computer experts
we're wrong
and when you start telling people
that all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates
when people start telling you that
you're crazy you just might be on to the
most important innovation in your life
there are lots of times especially in
the early days uh that were that were
very very difficult
i think i think the most difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its
had its only lost quarter in history and
we've been in business for 20 years of
this 20 years we lost money one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almost we doubled our
sales virtually every year for for ten
years
nine nine out of ten years ten out of
eleven years it was really quite an
amazing run we're the fastest growing
company in history still we still are
the fastest growing company in history
over a long period of time
and
suddenly we'd hit a wall
we would reach a billion dollars in
revenue and we were having serious
management problems all over the place
and the people who were running the
company at the billion dollar company
were the same people that run the
company when we were a 50 million dollar
company one twentieth the size
and i hadn't
had an incredible sense of loyalty to
those people who'd worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful
realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh
that people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those aren't the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse just entirely
different skill set in running a 50
million dollar company than a billion
dollar company
and uh
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means i had to ask people who i'd
worked with for a decade to leave i had
to fire people
uh
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business asking that yeah
a bunch of people to
leave oracle
i had no choice
i never even asked them to leave oracle
or everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh
thousands of people worked at oracle uh
they deserve the best leadership we
could find uh
and
my primary my primary responsibility was
to the company and
all all of the staff
you know all of our shareholders and all
of our customers
and uh
therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go nobody's got more
haters than that but it stops a lot of
people it doesn't stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me
like
i understand
that
if you get if you're going to get
success
you're going to get the haters that's
the price or one of the costs that's one
of the prices okay so because it goes
back to what i said earlier all haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do we even call them haters
they're not haters
they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is acquaintance
all haters all haters
including me anytime i hate on something
okay i am a i quit on that thing like i
hate drugs i quit drugs i hate drugs i
hate people that use drugs i don't trust
people that use drugs like no drug is
safe for me
and and i know i believe that no drug is
safe for other people now some people
will be like no no i'm using cannabis uh
recreational it's cool man and i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate trucks for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong but
right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you i'm
over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows so so if i'm doing
that okay and you're hating on me why
you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough he works too
much because you don't use you don't
work enough
he doesn't spend enough time with his
kids you don't even have kids like i got
people hating on me
because i got my kids on my plane oh
you're going to ruin your kids if i'm
going to ruin my kids i'm going to ruin
them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like so i it's very very important
for me like when i hate on somebody i
need to understand did i quit on
something or am i legitimately hating on
this person
for a reason because i'm trying to make
a i'm trying to make a statement
publicly and there are
there are people i publicly hate on and
why do you do that
because i want to make it clear that
they should not be doing business with
this person they should not be admiring
this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people
you don't want to follow that if you're
going to follow him don't follow me yeah
you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media the general theme i would
suggest is that all trends
are overrated
and so
if you think about current
trends in technology
you know
healthcare it software education
software
overrated
sas enterprise software really overrated
um
big data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can
and um and the reason these buzzwords
um
tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords they're sort of
like a tell in poker that people are
bluffing and that there's nothing that
there's uh that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore uh are symptomatic somehow of
of um a lot of competition and a bad a
bad business idea and so you know you
don't want to be the fourth online pet
food company you don't want to be the
10th in film solar panel company you
don't want to be the 1000th restaurant
in san francisco and so there is
something about if you can describe um
what a company is doing um very
straightforwardly by uh referencing um
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist um that's actually a
sign that it's a pretty bad uh that's
that's a pretty bad idea during my
california springs and summers i spent
most of my days in the high sierras in
yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i learned a program in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it
and computer pro programming gave me the
same kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife
was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this
time i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again my dream is for there to be many
more female inventors i'm hoping more
more and more women will have the
courage to
take that risk it's a risk to invent
something you have to risk being made
fun of you have to risk looking like an
idiot
you have to do something that didn't
already exist which is scary i mean my
brain told me a million times who do you
think you are coming up with this then
one day you wake up and you go well what
if it is me what is your thing and when
did you kind of understand what it was
it hasn't changed my thing is learning
learning whatever is new and applying it
in ways that other people aren't
thinking of and so when i started i got
fired from a job selling software
started a company and within six months
this was the early days of pcs i
recognized that okay we need to connect
pcs together back then you walked around
and you had your 500 quarter inch floppy
and you know who would need to connect
to pc
we started you know writing software for
local area networks became a systems
integrator 30 some million dollar run
rate and sold it to um h r block and
then got to the internet okay let's look
at this internet thing someone's going
to need to put audio and then video on
there great and then after yahoo did
yahoo right i'm like you know what i'm
looking at these big screen tvs that
cost thirty thousand dollars that are
high definition television sets and i'm
thinking you know what eventually
they're gonna follow the price
performance curve of traditional of
traditional consumer electronics
and they're going to come down to price
so i started the first all high
definition tv network called hdnet then
i'm looking and saying okay you know
what it's like 2006 2007 and traditional
television and cable is going um digital
i'm saying you know what there's going
to be more a lot of storage space and
first access digital space that cable
companies aren't used to using so let's
take a movie production company that we
created and let's make it available for
day and date distribution where people
can will pay
20 bucks
to the the cable company to watch this
brand new movie and we get to keep 10 of
it and so we
had 29 29 productions we started
producing movies and lo and behold the
first movie we created was a documentary
called enron the smartest guys in the
room i think there's a problem in in
western europe where um where failure is
uh
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over i think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in california
where i think sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people um
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um
uh uh that's you know that's that's
going to be
psychologically damaging you know people
have less confidence you there all sorts
of reasons why why that tends to be uh
that tends to be quite bad i think that
um i think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over-determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you work with the wrong
people the idea was bad the timing was
wrong it wasn't a monopoly the product
didn't work uh and okay next time i'm
working with different people you figure
out one out of the five things you're
likely to fail fail again uh so i think
i think uh failure is not something one
can learn very much from i think that's
sort of a myth that i i would challenge
um but what i think what i think you
should do when you when when something
goes badly wrong is um you just keep
going
you you do something else
and you don't dwell on the past i don't
think my personality has changed much
since i was five years old
i think
as i explained to the kids just a little
while ago
probably the single
most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success has
been my uh
my questioning of conventional wisdom my
doubting of experts just because they're
experts
and questioning of authority
and while that can be very very painful
in terms of your relationship with your
parents and your relationship with your
teachers it's enormously useful in life
and i'm going to tell you something that
a lot of people 99 of people disagree
with me on
right everybody says follow your
passions
i say this
right i say follow your effort
it's amazing how we're all passionate
about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans
helping this organization helping this
group that's great
but
no matter what it all nets out to where
do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something and you know what
i've learned nobody ever quits anything
they're great at
and once you get great at it's amazing
how passionate you become about it
follow your efforts
right because it's not in the dreaming
it's in the doing you talked about
companies having a unique advantage can
you speak more on that for me please
sure i mean
what is it that that
a customer can get from you that they
can't get from anybody else and you have
to be very careful with that too when i
just talked about lying to yourself as
an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber but it has pink cars uber
doesn't have pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature
pink uber cars
that's a feature that's not a unique
product excuse me so you have to know
what it is that you do
that is so unique people's the people
your potential customers say whoa
i did not know that as opposed to well
let me go tell uber that they should
probably add pink cars
because whenever you're competing with
them you know all of you are going to
compete with amazon at some point
if you're not already
just the reality
and so you've got to understand when
amazon starts looking at my customer
base what is it that i can convey to
them that makes me unique and that's
that's what i meant by unique difference
i know you all understand better than
most that real progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say that the single most
important lesson i learned in 25 years
talking every single day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood
i've done over
35 000 interviews in my career
and as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange
i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view and
help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation during my california springs and
summers i spent most of my days in the
high sierras in yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i had learned a program in college i
didn't love programming
but it was fun and i was good at it
and computer program programming gave me
the same kind of satisfaction
is solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember was a sailing class
taught at berkeley marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean when my class was over i wanted to
buy a sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again so mr buffett in the past you
invested in china south korea and israel
and recently you partnered with 3g
capital and joshua paul lemon um from
brazil over for the heinz deal
does this mean are you tempted to
venture into the brazil market next
i didn't get the question question you
did the heinz deal the question is are
you going to invest in brazil next oh uh
i don't know where i'm going to invest
next that's what that's what makes my
job interesting i mean
i'm i'm not kidding i mean if you went
out and played golf
and every drive went in the hole you'd
give up the game wouldn't be interesting
i mean
what what's interesting is when you get
in the rough and you have to come out
and a few things like that so i
i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow
and i never heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company ishkar the letter was a page and
a half long and he said
if he sold the company the family sold
the company the only company they wanted
to sell it to was berkshire hathaway and
if i was interested they'd be glad to
come over from israel and explain it to
me and it was a it just jumped off the
page that this was an interesting idea
so i emailed them and they came over
very shortly and
and we bought the business we we handed
them
four billion dollars for 80 of a company
where i'd never seen it or anything
eitan kept saying you got to come over
to israel and see the plants and
everything you won't believe how
wonderful they are and i said eitan
i don't go to council bluffs iowa you
know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and
he said no you know you got to see it i
said no no i don't i i said we can make
a deal without seeing it he said well if
you buy if you buy the company will you
come and see it i said if we buy the
company i'll come so we bought the
company and i went over there and it's
true i've never seen plants like this it
was the greatest operation i've ever
seen and etan said to me said you know
that's why i want you to come over to
see these things i said listen if i'd
come and see them i'd have paid more
money so
so it uh
we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with george apollo lemon and his
associates they are sensational people
uh i got to know george apollo when i
was on the port of gillette with him and
the opportunity to buy into a wonderful
business like heinz
and to be partners and they do
they'll do all the heavy lifting they
run the place uh with georgie pollon
associates i mean it's just
it's a it's a great opportunity for us
and i don't know what the opportunity
will be tomorrow with george apollo is
last december
uh
i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met and he
said i think i've got an idea might
interest you when i get out there so i
went out there and and uh and as we came
back on the plane he explained what he
was thinking about in terms of heinz and
i said
count me in and uh
and i'll tell you one other thing which
is quite impressive about him
after i said that and when went a little
a little further on the thing he sent me
a
one-page
governance description of how it would
work between the two of us and he sent
me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word how would you describe each phase
of the evolution of oracle and how would
you uh
sort of describe running each of those
phases you got to do this quick
oh my god well i mean and clearly
being a part of a company with four
people and being a part of a company and
by the way that's we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know uh on 100
uh we think about sun's got about 20 000
employees and you know uh 25 000
employees we're about 105 000.
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh what has not
changed is i ran engineering
at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to and i is always reported directly to
me is engineering not sales not
marketing not support and not consulting
not services at various points in time
lots of other people have run run those
operations the back office accountings
order management all of these things the
only thing that i've done consistently
during those 32 years is run engineering
because i believe basically that once
you reach the you will you know you'll
win as as we say at oracle it's amazing
our good products seem to do very well
and our bad products
not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage is developing
the right products recruiting the right
engineers and having the right
organization in the beginning nobody
wanted a tesla i can tell you that
uh
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to the sports car
uh
people were like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline
car works fine
i'm like no electric cars better i
should try it
um
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive
first one nobody knew who we were they
remember this company
and like yeah we're named after nikola
tesla you know that guy nope
um
so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said there was
no one telling us that they wanted an
electric car so it was not it was not
out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good um and then
people want them
um
you know it's like i think it was like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say a faster horse
so if you did like a big survey and say
hey what hey public
before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food and
uh
you know be stronger and
live longer and that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um
because people
when you say like what about an
automobile that car that drives itself
like what are you talking about that's
not that sounds crazy
um
but when you actually make an automobile
and give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
yeah
so carry more like more weight than a
horse and go further and that kind of
thing so
anyway
it's like when when it's a radically new
product people don't know that they want
it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey
i think this might have been like
46 or 48. it was like famous nationwide
survey will you ever buy a tv
now it was like 96 percent of
respondents said no
someone some crazy number
like basically everyone's like would you
buy a tv and maybe they put a price in
there or something i don't know but
it was famously
almost everyone said they would not buy
tv but they didn't know what they're
talking about
so the big game-changing stuff at the
beginning is a company push kind of a
thing most of the time but then
changes to the product over time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah change changes to the product over
time can be
incremental changes
um
then the customers can certainly tell
you it's good to get customer feedback
to say how can we improve the product
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over time customer
feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing is is great we
also are big believers in in united way
and and what goes on there and that's
more at a business level we sort of
think every business ought to do that
it's a basic thing because social
services uh we think have a a
deserved particular priority in terms of
drawing employees in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons and great stories get the
word out make it fun make it easy you
know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then we
send you no more email uh so we've
made it the easiest thing to do is is uh
is
participate in terms of individuals it's
quite different
you know you can take and give to groups
like united way who are really thinking
about everything in the community or you
can find things and most people mix this
you can find things that you're
particularly interested in that you know
about that a relative benefited from or
that you want to go and volunteer
in
uh you know microsoft does the thing now
for every hour that somebody volunteers
we actually
uh make a grant to that organization
because that says that there they care
about it and
they think it's it's doing very good
work
now for individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be
in the community where you know what's
going on
i'm a big believer that that the some of
the greatest inequities are on a global
basis
and so uh one of the things our
foundation tries to get out is the names
of a number of organizations like save
the children or global fund or vaccine
fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people
are able to be fairly generous that this
international component that it be part
of of what they're doing if we've given
the world a voice look at what's
happened in the last year you've had
elections in the last years elections
manipulated hate speech that's gone
viral and turned offline um it certainly
seems like this mission
has been accomplished in many ways and
and there's a whole new set of problems
that perhaps you guys didn't foresee um
and now we're in a very complicated
place where there's not an easy solution
yeah there's these are complex issues
that you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis
but
look
do you think that the world is better
with everyone having a voice and having
the ability to express their opinion
and being able to connect to who they
want i don't think we're going back to a
world where there were just a handful of
gatekeepers who got to control what
ideas get expressed
and even if we could well i'm trying to
make it so we're not i mean that's why
um making it so that we're building
these independent governance mechanisms
and things like that are really
important and that's that's work that i
that i really care about um
but i think that the world will keep on
moving in this direction um people will
more people will keep on getting a voice
uh i think that that's good and and and
i think there are certainly going to be
issues that we need to work through over
time but i think that while we are doing
that we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well
not just in terms of communities and
people being able to to connect with
with groups that are really meaningful
to them whether it's around a disease or
um or a community around veterans that
they wouldn't be able to connect to
otherwise but even if you just think
about the economic impact
of what we're doing um you know we serve
80 million small businesses around the
world
about half of them have told us that
they're hiring people because of using
our tools and that without facebook and
the tools that we that we provide and
they that their business would be
significantly smaller and they wouldn't
be hiring as many people as they are
so you know a study came out the us
economy added about four and a half
million jobs over the last year
if you just look at like what people are
telling us the small businesses who use
our tools
we've directly been able to contribute
to creating many more jobs than that
across the world so i think that
this is the power of giving people a
voice giving small businesses giving
communities giving everyone everywhere
the ability to connect with the people
who who they care about and get their
opinion across and giving everyday
people the power that previously only
big companies would have had so that's
it the world is going to go more in that
direction and i think by and large
that's a good thing so i'm really proud
of the work that we're doing on this and
we there are big issues and i'm not
trying to to say that there aren't that
we need to work through but i i do think
that sometimes you can you can get the
flavor
from a lot of this from from some of the
coverage that um
that's all there is and um and i don't
think that that's right either we need
to make sure that we address these um
these questions um these are really big
and important things for the future of
our society and the future of the
internet um but we also need to keep
pushing in the direction of empowering
more people
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a
down
hashtag
the comments below on this video i will
showcase you and celebrate you somewhere
on the screen in a future video because
you are awesome if you want seven more
amazing lessons from successful
billionaires check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there maybe it's we need to reignite
public excitement in mars so i initially
started off
with the idea of doing this like
philanthropic mission to send a small
greenhouse to mars
to get the public excited about